[Applause]
well we're in the 90s and we look like
we're all that and a bag of chips that's
right we're kicking it grunge style i
mean who doesn't love the sound of dial
up internet
[Applause]
trying to decide which spice girl we're
gonna kick it with back in an episode of
save by the bell ross do you think the
1990s are de bomb the 90s were amazing
saved by the bell 90210 melrose place
member everyone
the
bomb used to have parties at my house um
pizza parties and like you know wine and
beer and hang out and watch a double
feature of 90210 and melrose
yes and leonardo dicaprio would come
over sometimes you're trying what do you
what are you trying to do to me like all
he was friends with all of my friends so
like sometimes it'd just be leo kicking
it on the couch from melrose place now
um your parties were a little bit cooler
than mine okay well uh the 90s were so
iconic and there were many duos in the
90s ross and i are dressed as a coffee
house grunge couple ready to kick it at
a peck concert yeah you guys should
check out our new band yeah
um and we thought it would be fun to
celebrate halloween by catching up with
some of our very favorite
in 90s couples costume challenge
[Music]
[Applause]
and our audience will be getting jiggy
with it and voting for their favorite
okay are you ready for this yeah i'm hot
turns out it's hot under here yeah okay
let's bring out our first couple okay
[Applause]
[Music]
show and film wayne's world it's and
guard
um
by the way time travel i was in wayne's
world too as barrigan kerrigan that's
swedish
um tell everyone your names and how long
you've been together uh my name is riley
i'm ammon we've been together for three
years you're cute
[Music]
[Applause]
um
what is your very favorite thing about
halloween uh well it's actually hard for
me to pick one thing cause i absolutely
love everything about this season um but
i have to pick one it is designing our
costumes every year for halloween
um i put that on
i'd love it do you do you do an
impression of wayne's
okay let me hear it part of time
oh my gosh that's giving me all the
[ __ ] prizes
oh we love wayne and garth and we love
you guys friends we love you
thank you okay party on later
[Applause]
all right let's bring out our next
couple they are so cute okay who's that
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
by the way i love that you look like you
should be arrested
straight up what are your names and how
long you've been together oh we've been
together for three years tara and joe
joseph and joe where are you from
long island
eastern long island suffolk county okay
uh tara do you enjoy um running slow
motion on a beach all the pamela
anderson oh it's training drew for
just this past summer i ran wick first
5k really really yes wow that is
commitment oh my gosh that's good
it's been a wonderful experience truly
what did you do to get the character
tommy lee
i've been in character since i was 14
years old really yeah
wow i'd like to know what you guys i
grew up listening to 90s bands i play my
uh play guitar been playing for
self-taught over 25 years so that's what
relaxes me really my second my second
love guitar my first love right here oh
no
oh gosh oh come on you put the sweet and
pamela and tommy although we already
loved them but you guys are just taking
it up a notch thank you so much
great job
all right we're gonna see our last
couple everybody looks so good it's
gonna be tough
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
okay you are giving me prince vibes yeah
wow why i picked them
that's okay tell us your names and how
long you've been together i'm gabby
i'm frankie and we've been together for
four months
frankie i really love your name thank
you i love it so much i named my
daughter frankie i know it's so cute i
told him that before the show
you look like prince and do you get told
you look like prince in perth like on
the street yes every day every day every
time we go out we're like oh my gosh you
look so much like prince i think it's
because he's a strong silent type too
and then the look but yeah we get a lot
how did you guys meet
on tinder all right
um
okay uh gabby do you think that you're a
good dancer like my tay i am the 2020
tick tock version of my day because girl
can dance but i can do tick tocks
i've got all the rage now yeah i love it
ross everyone looks so great this is too
close to call i don't want to vote i
don't want anything to do with it i want
to remain neutral but there has to be a
winner drew there has to be it's a
contest all right well good because the
audience voted oh my god so here's the
good news why don't you step down and
all stand next to each other thank you
so much thank you audience for
doing the difficult work for us let's
see who our audience voted for all right
in third place
[Applause]
and some tamagotchis
that were very popular in the 90s you
have a tamagotchi no no no no
no she can't figure out tick tock she's
not figuring out a tamagotchi it's true
anything tech i want tactile okay i just
did all right in second place put your
hands together for
wayne and garth with 19
[Applause]
and you guys are gonna go home
with two disc commands oh wow a binder
full of cds oh that's so exciting sure
if that's a present or
not
but
well man we're gonna figure that out
and that means our first place winners
are pamela and tommy
[Applause]
each okay good all right
thank you so much
[Music]
you